Sollte eigentlich keine Probleme machen, ich hatte jetzt gerade Software-Encoding an,
jetzt habe ich wieder über die Grafikkarte das Encoding an, naja.
Sollte aber eigentlich keinen Unterschied machen, ich meine, ich habe jetzt 6 Kerne.
So, mal gucken, ob das jetzt, ja, jetzt scheint es zu funktionieren, ne?
Keine Ahnung, was da kaputt ist.
Na gut, aber jetzt geht's, auch schön.
So, Moment, ja, das muss ich wieder aufmachen.
Ich stream jetzt zum ersten Mal vom neuen Rechner aus, ich zeige euch mal was.
Sobald das richtig läuft, zeige ich euch mal was.
Was ist eigentlich das hier unten für ein Knopf?
So viele Leute, the fuck, geh weg.
Ich sehe jetzt mal einen Streamer, aber ich sehe keine Zuschauerzahlen und Chat und sonst
was.
Das wird jetzt wieder ganz doll, so mal gemacht.
Naja, aber ihr hört mich, oder?
Nur mal um das jetzt auf Nummer sicher zu gehen, dass das Prinzipiell alles funktioniert.
Ich mache jetzt einfach noch mal das Tab neu auf, sollte das eigentlich funktionieren.
Gucken, ob ich mich, ah, geht, ja, sehr schön, sehr schön.
Ja, jetzt funktioniert's und ich glaube jetzt, jetzt machen wir noch mal den ultimativen
Test, ob ich Aussatze habe.
Das heißt, wenn jetzt die Animation sich ordentlich dreht, dann wissen wir, ich habe
keine Aussatze mehr.
Ich verstehe, naja, so ganz flüssig ist das jetzt aber nicht, ne.
Ich muss jetzt, warum, wo ist das Problem, oh man, wo ist denn das Problem wieder?
What?
Warum habe ich dropped frames?
Hallo, ich nehme meinen Desktop auf und sonst nix?
Was ist das wieder?
Der Struggle ist real, ich mache noch mal aus.